my name is John Desmond and I'm the
senior director of software security at
DocuSign we serve 300,000 companies with
200 million users worldwide and we're in
188 countries security is absolutely
critical to everything we do at DocuSign
we build it into every process and we
have to modern software development is
not simply a question of build Wes's by
its build versus buy-in a bunch of third
party dependencies along with it and my
team have to evaluate whether that
component is robust Microsoft security
risk detection
ran millions of test cases across
multiple virtual machines completely
automated there was no additional setup
required from us the results are really
positive my team is constantly looking
to automate processes while retaining a
good level of coverage services like
Microsoft security risk detection allow
us to do exactly that
we certainly recommend Microsoft
security risk detection to other
companies that are looking for scalable
easy to use cutting-edge technology
worked in the security industry for 15
years as of Ocampo having this type of
technology available to us is hugely
beneficial to our team
[Music]